welcome to the presentation on age word
problems let's get started well i
already have one written down here it
says in four years
ali will be three times as old as he is
today how old is ali today well let's
just say that
x
that's a little too big for what i want
to write x equals
ali's
current age
or his age today
please forgive my handwriting
if x is ali's current age and here we
say in four years so how old is ellie
going to be in four years well if x is
his current age in four years he's going
to be x plus four years old
so that is equal to
ali's age
age
in
four
years
let's read what other information
there's a problem it says in four years
so
in this situation that's a four x plus
four in four years ali will be three
times as old as he is today
well today he's x so we say in four
years
x plus four
and that's just
so in four years
so we could translate that into x plus
four that's going to equal
3 times as old as he is today
well we know today he's x so that's
going to be equal to
3 x
and now we just solve for x subtract x
from both sides you get 2x is equal to 4
x equals 2.
so ali is 2 years old today
let's do another problem
that makes sense because if he's 2 today
in 4 years he's going to be six which is
going to be three times as old as he is
today so it all works out let's do
another problem
let's clear this and now i'm going to
attempt
to type
i hope i don't mess up
okay
the problem is
nazareth is four
years
older
than umama
two years
ago
nazareth
was five
times as
old
as umama
how
old
is
nazareth
today ah this one this one seems
more difficult
but i think we'll be able to get through
it
let's figure it out all right
so once again what we're trying to solve
for we're trying to solve for nazareth
today so let's say
this is nazareth
we'll say nas for short and let's say
this is a mamma
and this is
today i'm making a little chart
and let's say four years from now
four
oh no no not four years from now i'm i'm
confusing myself this would be
two
years ago i'm still remembering the last
problem two years ago okay so this
whereas today two years into the future
let me make a little chart
it's not the cleanest chart but i think
it'll do the job
okay so we're trying to solve for x how
old is natural today so let's just say
na is today that is equal to x
it says nazareth is four years older
than umama
so
this piece of information up here let me
underline it nazareth is four years
older than a mamma
well that piece of information tells us
that umami today if nazareth is x then
umami is going to be x
minus 4 which makes sense because she's
because nas is four years older than a
mama
now we go into the past
let's write let's
look at this
so two years ago
so if nas is x today how old was she two
years ago well she was going to be x
minus 2.
that makes sense if i'm 10 years old
today two years ago i'll be two years
less so i'd be eight years old so she's
x today two years ago she was x minus
two
and if a mamma is x minus four today
then two years ago she'll be two less
than that so she'll be x minus four
minus two and that equals x
minus six
which makes sense and notice that she is
still four years younger than nas or
nazareth
now we have one final piece of
information in this problem it says two
years ago
nazareth
was five times as old
as umama
so we're in this situation
two years ago that's what the senate
says two years ago so it's this
situation
nazareth was five times as old as a
mammal so nazareth which is x minus 2
was 5 times older than a mammal which is
x minus 6. so let's just write that down
so nazrath two years ago was x minus 2.
we get that from the chart nazareth was
x minus 2 two years ago
and that sentence tells us nazareth was
five times older
than who mammal was two years ago no
matter two years ago was x minus six
well now we just solve for x
x minus two is equal to 5x
minus 30.
now we could subtract
x from both sides and we could get 4x
i'm going to switch it around 2 to
hopefully confuse you more
4x minus 30 equals minus 2
and then we get 4 x
is equal to 28
and x is equal to 7. so we solved the
problem
nazareth today
is seven years old and does this make
sense well if nazareth today is seven
years old
then umama today is going to be three
years old and that makes sense because
there's a four year difference two years
ago
nazareth was five years old
and two years ago mama
was only one year old
right because x minus six so it makes
sense nazareth is four years older than
omam not earth is seven umami is three
right now two years ago in nazareth was
five times as old as a mama two years
ago in nazareth was five and new mammal
was one so it all works out pretty deep
no
well anyway i think you're ready to at
least try some of these age problems and
i'm gonna do some more example problems
so you can you can come back to this uh
this video page and see more if you're
still a little bit confused
have fun
let me turn this thing off okay